hey i'm alvin i'm a tasty producer and
today i'll be showing you how i came up
with my recipe for the five-layer
brownie cookie cheesecake
five-layer brownie cheesecake was
probably one of my greatest
architectural feats if i would say so
myself i was actually studying
engineering in college not really a good
student to be honest but one thing that
i definitely did pick up was the ability
of how to approach a problem and how to
look at it from certain angles
especially when things don't exist a lot
of times we're asked to do hypothetical
questions like if you wanted to
accomplish this how would you go about
achieving it and i learned that the
easiest way is to break down the problem
into its parts and kind of almost work
backwards cookie dough oreos and
brownies are very common combination and
i wanted to take that further i really
wanted to turn the flavor profile of
like a triple stacked brownie into
something else i wanted to turn it into
more of like this spectacle dessert that
you could really wow everybody at a
party with and i just absolutely love
layers and clean layers so that was
something that i set out to do was to
turn a triple decker brownie into a
cheesecake the challenge with this
recipe is that all of these elements all
bake at different times different
temperatures and have different
thicknesses i kind of wanted to go after
your vibe of when you go to cheesecake
factory and they set down this slice of
this beautifully cut and assembled
cheesecake i really didn't know how this
was gonna go until i made it and i had
to do a lot of pre-planning and thinking
and being able to try to predict how the
food would behave in a way that i had
never done before i was hoping that the
brownie batter would not get dry i guess
that the cream cheese and the mixture
would give the brownie moisture it's
really gratifying to pull something like
this off especially when you have never
really done this before i guess i feel
really happy relieved that it actually
worked after the brownie and cheesecake
were set that's when i put the oreos and
the cookie dough on top
i don't try to do recipes a lot of times
because i think i really enjoy the
challenge of getting it right on the
first of the second try kind of
nerve-wracking to cut it open because
you really don't know how it's going to
turn out until you actually slice it
open and see the layers and to my luck
it really worked out well i was able to
see
all four elements in their entirety i
love to spend time just thinking about
the food and really just trying to guess
and predict how food is going to behave
and sometimes they really just sit down
and write things down and try to map out
or draw out how certain foods would look
before and after and so for this one i
thought about it a lot and made some
decisions and that's the sort of
approach that i like to take because
there's something really cool about
trying something that's completely new
and then somehow landing it on the first
try so in my video i combined brownies
oreos cookie dough and cheesecake what
combination of desserts do you want me
to attempt next
i think that's it hopefully it's good yo
[Music]
you